Speaker 1: Let's go to the phones and buy phones.
We haven't really used phones in a long time.
We use discord at David Pakman dot com slash
discord. We are going to hear from some of you,
which I think is a really great thing to do.
Let's start with Jeff in Tulsa, Oklahoma. Jeff,
welcome to the program.
Speaker 4: Hi, David.
I really appreciate your efforts
to shoot straight with us and,
you know, not mislead us. Regardless of your
political position on an issue. And I think that
you stick to that almost all the time. But there's
one thing lately that I've noticed you continue
to repeat that I think is a little bit weird.
So I just wanted to ask you about that. Sure.
So you've talked about the pandemic stimulus
payments. And, you know, it's a popular right wing
talking point. You know, that Biden has created
all this inflation with the stimulus. And then
you like to say, well. If you're not
happy with Biden's stimulus payments,
then you have to be doubly unhappy with
with Trump's. And. My my issue with that is
I think that there's a massive difference between
the first round of stimulus payments that were
issued when, you know, we were still falling off a
cliff economically. And and then Biden's payments
which you know, that I feel like the economy
had recovered quite a bit at that point. So
I'm not even making a comment about whether I
think that Biden should or shouldn't have or
whether it's actually created the inflation that
it has. But I do think that there's a difference
between those payments that came first, regardless
who did them and those payments that came last.
Speaker 1: Certainly there is a difference.
They were also half the number of dollars that
Trump did. Right. So it was also the totality
of what Biden did is significantly smaller.
Would you agree with that?
Speaker 4: Absolutely.
Speaker 1: And then the other difference, I
would argue, is it didn't include the PGP,
which was so abused, abused and riddled with
fraud and contained so much waste of money
going to organizations that didn't need it and
and abused even by many of the very people on
the Republican side who were opposed to it.
So Biden didn't include that in his stimulus,
which also to me would seem to make it more
reasonable in a way. So, yes, I mean, nothing is
exactly the same. It was a different time. It was
half the amount of money. It didn't include PGP,
but sure. Yeah, I mean we can talk
about the details of the difference,
but for people who just blanket say Biden's
one stimulus is the reason for inflation,
but Trump's to have nothing to
do with inflation. I think those
people are either wrong or hypocritical.
Speaker 4: Yes, I agree with you on that
completely. I just think that it's a little
more nuanced than Biden did whine Trump did,
too. So we should feel doubly about about Trump.
Speaker 1: It is it is more nuanced than that. And
at every opportunity we're adding, that
nuance is feasible. I am glad to do it.
Speaker 4: All right. Well,
thank you for everything, David.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you
very much. Appreciate the call.